Do glasses really make us smarter?
Or does our intelligence predict our need
for glasses?
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and if you’ve
ever seen Revenge of the Nerds, or really,
any movie ever made - then you’ve probably
wondered, why do the nerds always wear glasses?
Is their eyesight REALLY worse, or are the
dumb jocks just too proud to wear them?
Well, like everything else out there - science
has an answer.
And this one - is kinda surprising.
Researchers at the Mainz University Medical
Center have conducted the first population-based
study on nearsightedness (people who can’t
see far away), and they found that environmental
factors may have more to do with it, than
genetics.
Now as far as eyesight problems go, nearsightedness
is one of the most common afflictions worldwide.
It can affect children from a very young age,
but our eyeballs continue to grow well into
adulthood - so even in our 30s, it can still
get worse.
In more severe cases, it can lead to all kinds
of complications, like retinal detachment,
macular degeneration, premature cataracts,
and glaucoma.
So it’s in our best interest to figure out
what causes this, and how we can prevent it.
Unfortunately, the answer - may not be the
one we want.
For their study, researchers examined almost
5,000 patients with nearsightedness, and found
that myopia - the technical term for the affliction
- becomes more prevalent, the higher your
level of education.
24% of the patients with nearsightedness - had
no formal high school education, compared
to 35% of high school and vocational graduates,
and 53% of university graduates.
What’s more, they found that nearsightedness
actually increases, for each year of school
completed.
Now it’s commonly accepted that genetics
play a massive role in our ability to see
- and that’s true to an extent.
But this study also examined 45 genetic markers
associated with myopia, and found that even
those have a way lower impact on the severity
of the disease, than education level.
So why is this happening?
Well, the current consensus is that the activities
we partake in at school - like reading, looking
at a whiteboard, or using a computer - are
rapidly deteriorating our vision.
But what can be done?
After all, we can’t “cure” nearsightedness
- we can only correct it, but even things
like corrective lenses and contacts - are
largely unsuccessful.
Some recent studies, have suggested that the
key to preventing myopia in children - is
exposure to sunlight.
So they recommend kids spend at least 15 hours
a week outdoors, and try to limit their time
with close-up activities, like TV and video
games, to 30 hours a week.
Now I know what you’re thinking - only 30
hours a week for video games?
That’s like, nothing!
You’re right.
And if you agree - then perhaps you’ll appreciate
this blatant plug for another channel I host,
called Rev3Games.
It’s a channel for gamers, by gamers - and
we do all kinds of stuff, including reviews,
previews, Casual Friday - which is a show
where we sit around and drink beer and talk
about what’s happening in the industry…
It’s a lot of fun!
And we’re always looking for new subscribers,
so if you like games - please go check us
out.
You can find us
at youtube.com/rev3games.